la stasi pourrait bientôt être dissoute
la stasi la police secrète en rda et pas
suppression est justement une des
exigences de l'opposition
les activités de la stasi seront
désormais répartis entre les différents
ministères sept policiers côte est est
l'une des institutions des plus craints
des débuts détesté d'allemagne de l'est
jérôme bonnet retrouvailles au petit
matin devant la prison de la stasi about
scène dans le sud-est de la rda les
témoignages d amnistier sont rares et
encore anonyme
même si elle a changé de nom la police
secrète est toujours là ça commence par
des sévices comme par exemple enchaîné
le détenu les pieds croisés les bras
attachés aux lieux ou encore les mains
accrochées par des menottes au barreau
de boue sur la pointe des pieds pendant
plusieurs semaines
c'est ce qui est arrivé à d'autres
d'étudiants aujourd'hui pour la première
fois depuis 1945 les portes de la stasi
la redoutable police secrète d'allemagne
delhaize s'ouvre cette prison de baho
102 renferme encore une centaine de
prisonniers politiques
le directeur dont certains dossiers sont
dans les mains du procureur est
aujourd'hui au pied du mur je dois vous
dire ici il ya beaucoup de criminels pas
seulement des prisonniers politiques
je sais qu'il y ait 15 de cette
institution
un écran de fumée il faut dissiper
ravaler la façade de la police secrète
une priorité pour le régime est-allemand
le puits que cette institution est
devenu la cible de toutes les
manifestations de rue pour la démocratie
même à berlin au siège de ses services
de renseignement considéré jusqu'à il ya
deux mois comme les plus efficaces du
monde
l'ordre du jour est pour renouvellement
ne sommes plus que l'ancienne stasi un
organe du parti
un organe et le comité central et
politburo secrétaire général ont
travaillé selon une nouvelle loi qui
déterminera notre mission
nos attributions servi malgré 8 milles
licenciements ces derniers temps la
sécurité est allemande existe toujours
ce n'est plus la sécurité d'état la
stasi mais la sécurité nationale
la nazis un changement d'appellation il
ne suffira pas à rassurer